[Musique]
en poudre dans un seul outil dans une
barre ou dans un jus le collagène se
glisse dans une multitude de produits et
de suppléments alimentaires
c'est un marché mondial qui devrait
atteindre plus de 6 milliards de dollars
d'ici 2025 le collagène une protéine
animale
la plus abondante
les eaux
mais en vieillissant la production de
collagène dans notre corps diminue
l'industrie propose donc ses suppléments
le projet sur les réseaux sociaux
l'engouement est grand des stars et les
influenceurs vante les bienfaits pour
une belle peau chevelure longue pour les
articulations les muscles et plus encore
les suppléments sont faits à base de
produits animaux bovins ou marin plat
que la gêne et soit produit à partir de
la gélatine qui tue soins des boeufs ou
un déport m ou à partir de sous-produits
de la transformation du poisson pour
exemple les écailles les eaux et souvent
il est hydrolysées donc décomposé on ces
acides aminés pour favoriser
l'absorption
la gélatine et plus connu est très
utilisé dans l'industrie alimentaire
comme nous explique monsieur suis
chercheur à l'université de guelph
et une fois extraite par la chaleur on
la transforme en poudre comme celle que
l'on connaît bien le jello un autre
exemple de l'utilisation très répandue
la guimauve qui est fait avec de la
gélatine
alors que le collagène hydrolysées qui
se retrouvent dans les suppléments et
fractionné par une enzyme est produit de
petites molécules qui vont se dissoudre
facilement dans l'eau
[Musique]
catherine adele est nutritionniste elle
analysé l'échantillon de produits
sélectionnés et répertorier les
recherches au sujet du collagène afin de
mieux s'y retrouver
il permet une certaine des études
concluantes c'est juste que l on était à
très court terme sur un petit nombre de
sujets mais il ya quand même quelques
revues systématiques méta analyse mais
seulement pour la santé de la pop les
douleurs articulaires pour les autres
choses il ya vraiment très peu d'études
qui s'est pas confiance du tout et puis
aussi souvent financées par l'industrie
de biais et aussi quelques études pour
l'instant sportive entre autres pour la
guérison des blessures et en heure mais
il manque d'études pour le confirmer
de plus il est difficile de savoir à
quel endroit le corps l'utilisera quand
on consomme du collagène le corps le
décompose en ces acides aminés puis elle
va utiliser
ni là où est ce qu'il en a besoin donc
même si le supplément comprend indique
par exemple que ça aide pour la peau ça
veut dire que l'accord va l'utiliser
le collagène est une protéine qui se
retrouve naturellement dans plusieurs
aliments que l'on pense à la viande le
poulet les yeux oui
nous fait en deux nuits
certains produits s'affiche comme étant
végétalien ouais donc en fait c'est pô
est le cas la reine c'est le protéines
animales donc ya pas de collagène
suppléments à base de plantes maintenant
on retrouve juste des extraits de fruits
de légumes de plantes mc des nutriments
qui peuvent aider à favoriser la
production de collagène dans le corps
mais c'est pas du collagène
[Musique]
ces pastilles effervescentes sont
composées majoritairement de vitamine c
ajoutez au collagène chat contre me
contre 1 5 gramme de collagène
pour produire du collagène le corps a
besoin d'acides aminés donc de protéines
mais aussi de certains nutriments comme
la vitamine c le souffre et le zinc son
défaut cofacteur on consomme un vrai à
lima il ya plein de nutriments qui
agissent ensemble en synergie si on
mange une alimentation équilibrée
avec un concombre nos besoins en
protéines le corps va avoir à ces acides
aminés de protéines pour la production
mais
il est parfois difficile de connaître
toutes les composantes des produits
santé canada est établi à 10 grammes la
dose maximale de supplément de collagène
apprendre par jour les grosses douleurs
dans le pied au cul des odeurs
par rapport au collagène l'uma m il ya
un risque parce qu'il peut qu'il peut
contenir des toxines des métaux lourds
vu que ça provient de partie des des
animaux des poissons pour quelqu'un que
par exemple les problèmes de reins de
foi ou pour les femmes enceintes
alerte dans ça peut être très dangereux
donc c'est toujours important avant de
prendre un produit d'en parler à son
médecin et son pharmacien pour monsieur
depuis la façon de consommer le
collagène est un choix personnel
[Musique]
selon catherine il est préférable de
miser sur les bonnes habitudes de vie
dans la majorité des cas à vous même
plus la peine d'investir sur
l'amélioration des habitudes de vie et
bien sûr avoir une alimentation variée
et équilibrée et est limité le tabagisme
l'exposition au soleil la consommation
d'alcool ça ça va avoir un plus gros
impact sur la production de collagène
d'encore que la prise d'eau du témoin
[Musique]